Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Finally, as everyone knows that text to image
AIs are capable of creating incredible photos,
digital art, whatever you wish, now
we seem to be conquering video too.
What? So we just write something, and
exactly that video comes out? Doesn’t
that sound impossible? That is so much
harder! You see, images is one thing,
but videos require a much greater understanding
of the world around us, so much more computation,
and one more secret ingredient that I’m
going to tell you about in a moment.
So, after Google has published Imagen Video, now,
NVIDIA is here with their text to video AI too,
and it’s not just real good, it can do
things that other systems can’t do yet.
So first, examples. Of course, we start out
immediately with a scholarly example of two pandas
reading a paper. Approved. It is also excellent
at time lapse videos, I love this one. We can
also let our imagination run wild with this one,
for instance, we can even ask for a stormtrooper
vacuum cleaning a beach. Very productive. Artistic
scenes work well too, here is the look out of a
rainy car window, but in the style of a Van Gogh
painting. Apart from a little flicker, this is
excellent. Now, what about natural phenomena? You
know that my favorite is fluid simulations, so we
have to look at one of those too. This is easily
good enough to make me crave coffee. This swimming
turtle is also a delight to look at. And these are
not some tiny, stamp-sized videos, we are getting
a sequence of are approximately 2000x1000
resolution images. Wow. That is incredible.
I also liked how well this new paper can
deal with camera movements. Flying into
a fantasy landscape worked really
well, and I feel that this rotating
camera around the grapes is just one
paper away from near perfection. Wow.
And these results are already very
impressive, but hold on to your papers,
because you have seen nothing yet. This can
do so much more than just text to video.
With this, we can use our own characters to create
a movie out of thin air. You see, here is a bunch
of images of the test subject. Kermit, is that
you? Alright, now let’s ask the AI to make it
play the guitar. That is fantastic, but that’s not
the way of the True Scholar. The way of the True
Scholar is writing research papers. So, can it do
that too? Oh yes, yes it can. Good job, little AI!
It can also generate these driving sequences.
So what is that good for? Well, of course,
to feed hypothetical situations to a self-driving
AI, so it can have a look at footage and practice
safely within a simulation before bringing
its knowledge into the real world. Loving
it. But wait. These are all quite short
sequences. So what about video length? Well,
worry not a second about that one! It can
generate videos up to 5 minutes in length.
By the end of their example, I saw at most a
tiny bit of degradation of quality or even less.
And it can predict an entire video sequence
from a single image. That is also excellent
for self-driving cars. Why? Well, just
imagine giving it a starting scenario,
and it can simulate hundreds and
hundreds of potential variants of
this situation to train these
AIs. What a time to be alive!
So how does all this black magic work? Well,
let’s pop the hood and look inside. Oh yes,
this is going to be excellent. I mean
not this, the one after this. You see,
this is a diffusion-based technique, which
means that it starts out from a piece of noise,
and gradually reorders these pixels to form
an image. But, there is a problem. Do you see
the problem? These images are completely fine,
but they don’t form a coherent video. However,
look at that! After the new proposed
temporal video fine-tuning step,
look. Now we’re talking! This is truly a
coherent video in the making. Loving it.
And that temporal coherence is the
secret ingredient that I promised
that makes all this work so well. So good.
Now, not even this technique is perfect.
Asking a koala to play the piano is a bit
too much. However, I bet that the First
Law of Papers applies here. The First
Law Of Papers says that research is a
process. Do not look at where we are,
look at where we will be two
more papers down the line.
By the way, I just came across this. This shows
the length of Two Minute Papers videos over time.
From the first episode to 700 and beyond. It
used to be shorter. Can’t argue with that,
at this point it’s a running joke that Two Minute
Papers is never two minutes. But I wanted to
ask you. What do you think? Should these be
shorter? Let me know in the comments below.
Now, I haven’t found the source
code for this paper yet, however,
there will soon be an episode about a
way for you to try to create videos like
this soon. If you’re interested, make sure to
subscribe and hit the bell icon to not miss it.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!